[Applause]
today whose title is a blockchains
micropayments and zero knowledge proof I
think probably most of you maybe not all
know the model the Simons Institute
where we have programs that are
dedicated to special topics in computer
science plus sometimes related field
where we bring together visitors from
all around the world both postdocs and
senior researchers to collaborate on
these topics and today it's really
dedicated all to cryptography in one
form or another and you know both I and
the first speaker maybe I should say the
first speaker and I hey where students
graduate students at Berkeley a both
pd's on a lot of things that you'll see
today
I think I'm Origen it actually knows
early days in Berkeley so it's sort of
nice to have this full circle though it
doesn't end we continue right ok I'm not
paying any attention ok so so so we have
full agenda today as you saw and we have
two long breaks one is lunch and then
there's also reception but you know
together everybody in this field is a
little flexible so if you want to cut
two minutes over a few minutes I'm there
it's all good for example I'm gonna be
definitely under in my talk because if
by then I think people are gonna be
quite tired and here there are supposed
to be researchers scientists industry
academia entrepreneurs lots of students
from block chain at Berkeley who's here
a student from block two in Berkeley
very active in group in Berkeley that is
undergraduates right that sort of taken
on the whole idea of block chains quite
early on and they are really the spirit
of interpreter ship and graduate
students ok I don't want to insult
anyone ok so and finally I very much I
would like to thank our sponsors
protocol labs and Kennedy so I think
that representatives here from both
places who helped us put this event
together so I hope you enjoy the day I
think is it like this of really great
speakers I mean we paid attention to
who's speaking and it is recorded and
hopefully we will get permission to post
it later but we have an
sort of prepared for that in advance so
with that I will invite the or one and
only Silva my colleague who to start off
and as I said Silvia was a graduate
student at Berkeley in the early 1980s
and then he went on to University of
Toronto and then to MIT where he's been
ever since now he's in Algren he's a
founder of his Auburn and in any case it
was really fantastic he's one of these
creative people that I have ever met and
I would say that he deserves the title a
genius any four moves by anything any
standard that you you can think of he
really never ceases to amaze me
their way he sort of embarks on the new
enterprise research-wise
with impact in the world and such guts
so is thank you all right thank you very
much a chef a greater pleasure to be
back in in Berkeley at the base I'm Anza
and thank you for organizing this
special day you guys have really a lot
of technology to stay stay stay put stay
calm stay hydrated going on so I want to
tell you about alga and by the way let
me claim right away something but these
is an alternative blockchain is a little
bit different from from by others and
there's been a developer for first
principles sometimes is easier to start
from scratch and try to patch whatever
already exists and enable continuous
progress what does this mean who knows
but if I don't know answer that question
you should bring it up because I think
it is a particular part of orbit
they cannot obey technology to some
technologies needed to guarantee base so
here is the blockchain promise right
it's a great promise who doesn't like
i'm uncorruptable
database who doesn't like transparency
who doesn't like generating trust from
the middle of nowhere and enabling
people who barely know each other to
transact over
with a great trust everybody so the
application and the use cases of
blockchains are unlimited however there
is a very much an open secret
blockchains do not exist in fact block
chains are very much aspirational okay
and there is not been the chronology
truth to support them and by the way it
is very good idea to really raise the
bar of our aspirations as you want but
bets our fate to want more and more and
more but at some point if the technology
doesn't support our aspiration it will
remain a pie in the sky
so is this me I would say that now you
know the famous blockchain to ulema to
talk sure our specials are is due to a
metallic buddha who is really very found
the raw material is a very famous
blockchain and he famously said you know
if you want a blockchain you can enjoy
at the most two of the following three
properties
decentralisation security scalability
really so let me explain what does it
mean blockchain by design welcome so
what do you want the blockchain
excellent which property do you want to
emit from your blockchain security
great choice move it security
nobody perhaps you want to the omitted
decentralization well what do you want a
blockchain alright so about scalability
do you want a blockchain for friends and
family what are you trying to do so
these are Barry's know best remember is
not acceptable it's like if I tell you
do you want to be shot on the left knee
or on behind me
there are no good choices in better
women okay and is not acceptable and
never mind this is actually false okay
so let me tell you what are the trophies
the truth is that blockchains are
technical constructs and they required a
lot of technology you can get there but
you're going to get a lot of technology
and you shall see some from us and rock
chain of hinted for me from from ollie
is going to be so you need technology to
realize these aspirations period so let
me tell you what the challenge is right
so you know what is a blockchain I don't
have to define is the sequence of blocks
nobody can alter the content on the
block and nobody can alter by order of
the block that is the easy part
because all block chains achieve it in
the same way you take the previous block
you hash it one way I should and you
make mr. 32 bytes a part of the next
block you achieve all these tamper proof
- thumper order tamper everything what
is the challenge the challenge is rather
different is choosing the next block
right because if I choose it and you say
well no thanks right so how the hell we
choose the next block and by the way
there is actually some very popular
approaches in all let's go for it
briefly proof of work by the way wide
yet to choose remember the block so we
are this we want we don't want to
centralize anything so if I want to
transact I take my transaction which I
assume is valid a I'm going to pay a big
enough money to pay and I propagated I
send it to ten people who sent it to
each of one were sent to 10 people and
we make sure that we don't repeat
whatever we say in the so we finish ok
at any point in time you may see bees
fasten transaction of they look about it
to you somebody else in Thailand this is
this about fasten transaction of course
he or she sees this most of my think
when you see but you know there is a
half propagation delay they are not
coinciding and that's a lot of a
difference because if this has happened
or bases up and party girl if you
continue to do so it makes a lot of
difference so to you you think bases of
a block
somebody else I think this is the block
somebody else I think this and bases the
block who has very write up and the
block so Nakamoto is she or Bay and this
actually brilliant idea to say you know
what it's called proof of work we make a
very hard complex cryptographic riddle
and the first one who solves it has a
right to open the block okay so okay now
that is clarify even the solution really
is a block cut paint of a block of bits
the next block in between what is the
poem of Base first of all beta basic
consumes a lot it's very expensive
consumes a lot of energy hits the planet
Eire right so there are reaction
reaction jackson or computer tend to
solve all these miss computational
riddles and out and this is bad that
because it's very expensive so right now
this cost is subsidized by by minting
new bitcoin to give the to by people who
solve the block but once the subsidies
are something that we go away yet to pay
for it and who pays of it where people
want to put insert the transaction in
the block so he goes between 15 20 50
bucks per transaction so but it's not
exactly a way to buy a pizza right so
it's very expensive and the second of
all is very slow it takes 10 minutes a
block this why because necessarily so
right because is is a system is designed
so baton no matter how many people
participate you find one solution every
10 minutes
why because whenever you find two
solutions a few second of each other one
here and one in Italy somewheres of our
two solution then you have a fork
because we have two legitimate blocks
people who have a legitimate right to
upend the block and then the one that is
a fork of one of those of branches dies
and fewer payment is one of these
branches you can feel secure because you
don't know what happens so if you budget
for one solution every 10 minutes you
occasionally before but the system can
cooperate because but if you say
hey how about you produce a block every
minute by making very little easier well
if you budget for a solution at any
minute now the possibility beta we are
going to have the two solutions of the
second of each other it goes much higher
and you are going to have essentially a
fork of a fork of a fork a spaghetti
mess where you didn't see where ever him
is the longest chain okay
that's right so by the way I understand
expensive and fast expensive as well
it's a hard sale okay but nonetheless
beg our buyers okay that's good
they have Aponte's is also centralized
to the point but this isn't a
centralized blockchain are coming
why because once you see this is racks
and racks of computers just google it
apartment how many people can you afford
it
if I try to mine bitcoins with my laptop
in expectation I lose money
why because I'm pace of electricity
right now Simon's is paying thank you
very much shopping but otherwise you
know a little bit of trigger I pay in my
pocket but the probability that I solve
every riddle is so small but in
expectation I lose money the only way to
hope to be profitable or breaking even
is to have such a big Hardware
investment that very few people can
actually do it
bottom line right now Bitcoin is
controlled by three mining pools okay
all abroad by the way where energy is
cheaper and by the way where it's
cheaper because usually Bay they conjure
up the local official will sell them you
know fortune okay that's how it works so
it's free decentralized are you kidding
me
free is completely centralized right
they are much more large bands than the
free mining pools okay so that is
Israelis bizarre always an ocean of beta
the centralization is coming a
journalist talk about philosophers
sociologist anthropologist nothing is
coming nothing is decentralized yet okay
Peter alright next idea delegate apropos
snake is a simple idea
essentially means you see both the 21
people over there they look so honest
let's put them in charge to choose the
very next block on behalf of all of us
isn't by cc yes it is
but is this decentralized no it's
centralized from the get-go but those
people are always the were little people
losing interest in being honest all the
time but independent of it you can
actually attack them
once it is anything if you ever fix that
group of people by denial of service
attack you know both the bolts of it to
generate junk messages and you throw it
against one person 21 people in fact a
thousand people if you want so they're
buffers a fool or junk they cannot see
anything elements we have a buffer
overflow what was that job or scouting
around for a legitimate transaction to
put in the next block they can see
anything so the blockchain grinds to a
halt and you know what the prices of
denial of service attack five minutes
five dollars so choose somebody you hate
and you want to put them up with five
five dollars done 21 people bad idea
okay alright next bonded proof of stake
it's another simple idea say oh I bought
the proof of steak rare whatever it's
called delegator
they had bound that good so let me tell
you what the bond it is let's summarize
for you what that means that we allow
not just twenty people through some a
block by a lot twenty people two hundred
people two thousand people as many as
they want two people to put some money
in the middle of a table we're making
not touch it and the people who put the
money on the table are the ones in
charge of selecting the block on behalf
of all of us and their influence in so
selecting the block is proportional to
the amount of money be put in the table
and eat babies behave their money is
confiscated
Wow Betsy has to be the solution right
well that's possible let me ask a much
simpler question how much of your
disposable income can you afford to put
in the middle of a table where is not
invested not in stocks not involved but
is hostage the answer is very little for
some so what happens in a system
this human you actually roll a big red
carpet for big thieves with deep pockets
to put a disproportionate amount of
money in the middle of the table for the
sole purpose of controlling the
blockchain this is a controversial point
I'd like to devote a few more seconds
but first I want to continue with my my
my thing because there is no the first
of all the notion also that money can be
confiscated is a fantasy because there
is a lot of very very subtly bad people
but these much fewer bad and stupid
people so in order to have my money
confiscated I must do something overtly
public but allows somebody to confiscate
my money there is plenty of bad things
that I can do so for instance in the
journal I want to transact and I don't
want to them contact assume it varies an
auction done on chain and I don't want
to my competitor so to put their bids
right i bribe or whoever is over very
sighs the dome don't put the buzzbaits
and what do you say how come Fitz get
very mad if I didn't put my bids I
didn't see a bit however here we are
going to probe and confiscate the money
that is a fantasy okay forget the base
punishing people it very rarely works a
favor so the point is in all these
things let me tell you what today logic
questionable logic based system type and
it's the logic goes out the base they
all economy works if the majority if the
small piece of economies is aurorus and
this is sorry what apologies based
indeed I don't see the logic either so
how could it be that you take away all
like only at the mercy of a small piece
of it who is the small piece of it over
here are these the preeminent poles over
here are the 21 delegates and now over
here are the people put money in the
middle of the thing but can't be a big
piece of economy now there is no
relation between Benari on the table and
the value of the economy Elsa
right so assume it even EverBank okay we
are going to a bank of the blockchain -
where is the money of a bank loaned is
not in the middle of a table so I can be
a huge financial institution right was a
horrendous amount of holdings I'm not in
the middle of a table so in the middle
of whatever is a position of danger and
very few people are unproductively
Austin you just imagine that most of the
money is unproductive you choose a
medium or a table the economy goes
nowhere
okay that is a beta Bay the problem so
what do we have in mind we have in mind
something else which we call it pure
proof of stake let me tell you
intuitively what it is and the realizing
it is all by secret sauce but you need
the math finally you need the algorithm
finally you need economics plants a
foundry so first of all no punishments
everybody loves punishment right so if
you steal like cut off your hands that's
good makes me feel better but you know
it rarely works in fact he has never
worked okay people have stolen all the
time no matter if you put that side down
on about my farms about it so much
better idea is to make sure that
cheating is impossible
second part is where is your money is
where it should be at your fingertips in
your wallet invested in bay various
financial tools that blockchain offer to
you and when you take in consideration
all of this money productively used or
productively ignored in and proactively
ignore if the majority of a manager
understands the system works so this is
the first time in which you're going to
have the economy works even majority of
economists water to work what could be
majority was already sinking economy yes
be good but somehow is not exactly for
them very rational
different is to say if a minority
controls it to say but when they think
back all will be sink when sells sure
but it is a small piece let me give you
something let me say how much should you
have your invested investor gone a
million let's make a two million in cash
different economy okay Fiat the currency
and you say you know think your assets
and you do if you do it over majorities
are totally different the story ok so
that is the idea behind the pure prefer
stake in the by the way
sonar we two stacked a little bit about
the chronology what is very about Al
Gore on the idea of allergen is bit we
want to choose the next block how about
we agree with each consensus on the next
block and when I thought about doing
this I was saying that is ludicrous you
know McCauley so usually CBO from my
friends but Macaulay is wrong it would
be proven wrong because this is never
work okay
not quite first of all let me tell you
what the Byzantine agreement is is
actually very strong technology
developed in the eighties and is a
communication portable say among the
people in this room think of it such a
better we could talk and talk and if a
majority of the participants are honest
two things properties are guaranteed
agreement no matter what values we can
start with in our mind at the end of a
conversation all honest people agree on
the same value you can see which honest
and dishonest by easily okay
second property consistency just in case
everybody starts with the same value
then all honesty people not alone let
alone will available agree on a common
value but they agree on the very value
in which they start by the way achieving
this is easy why because you say here is
abundant in agreement it takes one step
no matter what the value is how to put
zero yes ma'am
ugly every honest follow the rules agree
on zero but my point is that if you
start 127 you should agree on the same
just is the case that everybody starts
with penetration agree on 23 you have to
think about it we don't have any time
but we have three seconds to absorb it
one two three what a great ok what is
the relation
are these name values you know what the
biz dev balazar I what in your mind and
your mind and my mind the next block is
going to be okay
so we want to agree on on a common book
possibly the empty block sometimes but
it's important to keep us together and
that's what we do all right
hey this is a 1980 technology there are
Byzantine ikeda protocol there is a plug
plug in none well not so fast
this is abysmal is law Byzantine
agreement you know what people look at
we keep this consistent and keeping with
an agreement three players the highest
number of players ever conceived in a
practical Byzantine agreement was 12
highest so now we want to do you know
you know between the billions of people
that's a little bit we need different
Byzantine a given protocol a moreover is
predicated on the fact that the number
of players are fixed and known in
advance over the internet enough
permissionless blockchain where
everybody is going to who knows what is
in it right now and who knows and how
many more people are going to come in
nothing is fixed right so not only is
very slow and you are always challenges
but no mistake about it so the secret
sauce of the consensus mechanism in
algorithm is really delivering Byzantine
agreement on a planetary scale with
unparallel efficiency period why say
budget in agreement because what
sometimes when people can not deliver a
Byzantine agreement they deliver it X
Byzantine agreement for instance
practical Byzantine agreement is all
Katia buys an agreement is a Byzantine
agreement is practical no I think the
agreement is something practical
Byzantine agreement is something else
could be a tort to us a different object
ok completely different and but because
you are it my mind is stuck combatant in
agreement you think it is what is in
modifiers is an adjective modifies the
noun it takes a whole different meaning
altogether this actually is Byzantine
agreement like peace shorten Lamport
defined for us
all right so let me tell you what this
what agree what does it mean that to
agree on a block of one by one and let's
see in action okay here is block number
one by the way
block number one so called the Genesis
block in every block chain you don't
need to agree on anything because he's
agreed by definition is part of the very
specification of a proverb all right
one block we have no problem agreeing
with the Genesis block be one next to it
buries a favor a I would say universal
symbol of lightness and
effortlessness and as base favor
effortlessly falls down the chain starts
unfolding okay
that's how it works and now you have a
chain Jesse Sylvia didn't you make it a
little bit too easy
where are the pores we reasonable for
work or is this favorite business well
the hand of Orcs why because we agree on
every single block so there is not
statistical process that may actually
sometimes a fork so there is no Forks in
the there is no proof of work of it is
the work is a bit of agreeing but as I
said it's very fast to work because it's
a super fast Byzantine agreement so if
you leave it at this stage and I want to
leave it at a stage for now here are the
differences
the first one is transaction finality so
once you see a block you can rely on it
right away you don't have to wait or
fear there is going to be another branch
that is going to overcome and close this
best branch to die so you can rely the
right away which is an important thing
in a financially
environment that there is enough release
Casimir is the last risky wanted to do a
wire transfer say with some probability
by money money money vanishes
now we know the old way economy you
start or Grandda to alter and the base
situation in what does this mean this is
really easy participation uni with a
laptop for non other ways you can
actually participate because the work is
required is very but it should because
you want but the only people who can
sink a big economy is the majority of
economy so you really have to feet to
figure out better your influence and you
were invested interest the more money
you have you're invested interest you
have better economy works and who can
sink in in al gore and the economy by
majority of the money it cannot be but
is our minority anybody won't want to
sink it so you have to remember but you
know sinking is so you want to have all
kinds of property that do not disappear
so in other words you want to say you
want to make sure that nobody senses you
as long as you know there is a good
old-fashioned 10% a better way owners
that I'm going to
nobody senses you the other thing is to
say hi 1 to base blockchain to grant to
hold and now the interests are aligned
because you need for this right because
of it is where we have a danger but you
have you find you know very few laborers
who control a very little of economy
destroying the core will be destroying
whatever they own in the economy must so
what I can write a composition yes yes
so you don't take which I don't the
question it's only then everybody has
the same value that you must have put
the same value so is it when the
following algorithm work with except for
vanishingly small which is always out
with you and now in the exceptional case
I think I said this you must have been
destructed I'm saying so I'd say the
better if you want buzzient in a game it
means to have agreement inconsistency
and if you care about agreement without
consistency you can always have to put
zero okay so then the best basis but is
not - I'll tell you one thing if
questions are at any time best question
is a bit easier when you see a bit
general architecture all right
no now you can ask any time so let me
tell you a summary right so the main
assumption is this honest majority of
money right by the way best wins over
anytime over honest majority of
computing power which is whatever up and
simple for work why because money is
fungible so if somebody has more money
than he can by setting more computing
power and Benny can even more majority
of computing power so that is as low as
you can go in my opinion but here is the
main technical advantages then one take
advantages but the computation involved
this streamer a few addition a few
comparisons signing a message verifying
a digital signature nothing to write
home about everybody could do it to the
centralization you donate the users and
miners right users and delegates users
and money in the table guys yeah but one
class of users all the people with the
money
no exogenous power finality of payments
you say there are no Forks where am i
right there is a probability of 14 which
is 10 to the minus 18 10 to the minus 18
which is a very strange number of
courses
range because I made it up but let me
tell you why I made it up because 10 to
18 happens to be the number of seconds
from the Big Bang until now in the
universe so another way to do it to say
it is that if you can produce a block a
second
which is pretty good clip it's going to
take you may see a fork but yet to wait
from the age of an universe to see it
you know at this point you know it's no
no no I mean to break the crypto you
have to wait more than a universe as you
know right because there are so many
seconds so many any art so many
elementary particles each one is a
supercomputer you know if if you're the
good cryptography this is when a system
fails is not because you've you fail the
hashing of the things you fail by some
other structure right okay so then the
scalability well the best scales as much
as you can the wine by sense but you can
generate block as fast you can propagate
them in some sense you cannot generate
faster if you want to ever a
decentralized system why because you're
not to know what the people's block is
before validating whether the
transaction visible occurs valid or not
in our system say Bitcoin for instance
you have artificial delays never mind of
us terminate to appease but you must
make the ten minutes wide to avoid too
many Forks right so that is there is no
other bottleneck here
and so finally very security against a
biodiversity how bad very bad so what
does that mean that means the phone
limit even if an adversary can corrupt
any player up to say a third of a
player's and I can perfectly control and
coordinate all the bad player and can
attack both the protocol and the network
I'll go and insecure because as shopping
sites they keep that secure okay so it's
not there all the rest of infrastructure
fades in the background
the only point is but can you forge a
signature yes or no if you can't but
it's nothing you can do by the way all
day when talking about the security most
of the time we talk about attacking the
corridor but the protocol is run on a
communication network so why should that
adversary attack only by protocol have a
vendor communication network
how can i attack the communication I
talk I don't know you can cut wires you
can reconfigure routers you could do all
kinds of things and you know under this
type of attacks and all Bitcoin
completely collapse even if all miners
are orders okay easy easy so better so
but not not not I'll go and he's secure
in both the sense and by the way should
we be saw diverse area yes because
decentralized economy is really well
should be worth a trillion dollars okay
easy so when you have targets of this
value bad actors are going to spring up
from the middle of nowhere like
mushrooms after the rain so you must
really be cut there and don't say oh
very going to be a chivalrous at the
basic attacks the potable interact or
they can attack anything that moves okay
so now tell me a little bit how the
architecture about gun works and they
also within some things are hopefully
your question wish so I'll go and walks
in to magic faces parentheses the magic
is actually replaced by mathematics
about the never mind is easier to talk
about the magic to you okay so face one
is by proposal face here how it works a
random token in selected a silver a ten
billion target circulation is randomly
selected how by magic what's the magic
face right so best talking selected then
best talker must belong to some public
key this public key by magic is clear
the obits the public key or Shafi okay
and what the barbecue shop it belongs to
sharpie and Shafi proposes a block
digital sign and so on
in this magic face you see a block sign
by Shafi you know that Shafi as a
vulnerable target randomly selected this
is a block of it a better shot has
proposed thanks to a thousand tokens are
random selected again by magic their
keys becomes publicly known by magic and
what do we do with people these are some
people they reach Byzantine agreement on
the block proposed by Shafi the maximum
was 12
now there is a thousand but if it is
true but wasn't in agreement is very
fast we can certainly debate okay why do
we want this second phase because in any
society and a blockchain is no exception
there is a percentage of bad actors okay
criminals 1% 2% if you live in a very
dangerous society 10% I want to ruin
myself you live in a society 20% of bad
actors you should not leave the house
you should do our thing it's ok but even
so they will never be in majority but
bad actors because what is a society's a
group of people which exists in so far
wave majority which follow certain rules
if nobody falls over rules there is no
society period
ok so let's assume we live in a
dangerous society 10 percent of us are
criminals so if you select things like
this ten percent of the time you're
going to get a bad actor and what can a
bad actor proposing a blog too simple it
can tell you that block physics can tell
somebody else the blocks ey can tell
some loggers in the block is e putting
in this scored the chain we taught to
believe it so that's why we have the
second phase because no matter what
value start with from the proposer you
ended up at a single book if the
proposal is honest you are forced to
agree on the broker if it's not it's not
honest you agreed on a block of valid
transaction anyway and why
so delicious problem in the sense that
there's but but who says that this is a
fair block of my roadblock nobody yet
because shop is in a deposit on a
project and how after basis she will
know our project works but is good I'm
not I'm not so okay so so you see for is
their various a and ninety percent
honest majority can it be Betty select
some thousand things people are random
and yeah but disorders the majority now
that is a really probability feel
incomplete about believe over B is very
very small so that's what happened
so when so they never these guys are
going to agree on some block of it that
contains in Bali transaction and they
never but when we agree we agree on the
same block and now to share this problem
to say if somebody is a dishonest what
can it be
but maybe consents or Ally we want to
put a trans actually you don't put the
shallots transaction but what is going
to happen next phase starts immediately
after so some random token is selected
whoever it belongs to select if this guy
is rst puts all honest almost once
action he sees in the block he doesn't
exclude anybody so at most we have a
little bit of a delay right but this
should I be online all the time
yes and now so let me explain it but
they also you should think is yes and
there and it is easy so let me actually
to do is something might be the more
sophisticated if it is going to take in
all tons of analysis it put in the
background let me ask you a difference a
different question how many times do you
switch off Gmail to save electricity
exactly so you don't assume a way very
bit I pay you too big to give it on
would you switch it off no so that is
so the idea is better if you reduce the
participation cost to essentially
nothing and on top of it by the way by
participating you actually gain a lot
then you don't take it off another case
so to have more sophisticated answer we
allow to have also online and offline
participation but a battery it's
important that you declare whether you
are offline honestly at the beginning
okay but it's a bit more sophisticated I
it's a very thing it's but you know I
have an hour what which half an hour is
gone and works okay or if it doesn't
work we can disband our selves a lot of
things have happened and but yes a bet
is something to do over all the rest of
a structure of a protocol so yeah but
probability epsilon or breaking the
crypto in a probability say alpha of
doing anything else and this alpha plus
epsilon is easily sorted but it's one
element but it's also other relevant to
my analysis that is just one of them
appears now all right okay it's clear
somehow how it works okay so okay better
iodine level are works okay by the way
say say Thank You Celia for your very
high level in explanation I have one
question one question you should be
thousands of questions alright so let's
actually analyze free because that's
what we have time for and by the way
this analysis we're going to do
something weird and you should expect
something weird to happen because if we
don't start extracting rabbits out of a
hat we are going to fall into the
pitfalls of Bitcoin Exeter Exeter
so the first and most popular question
is the following if I understood
something they all power all this
business
is based on selecting by committee right
so how who should select a committee
that the committee is selected so Beth
make a knocking on the door but to
select the committee let's assume that a
w I do move is the most centralized
system in yoruba center of it let's
assume that I said well the humanity
debates to select a committee and when
the committee agrees on the block we all
die before we are given anything let
alone on a fossil strong committee so
here is what we'll be doing something a
bit unorthodox in which is the committee
members select themselves what that is a
terrible idea
in fact it is actually maybe by second
worst idea ever proposed because if I am
a bad actor of course I self select
myself to approve this block and I self
selected myself to pool by next block
Exeter Exeter Exeter but not so fast
because you know to self-select Gautier
to do is battir to run your own
individual lottery and the lower is
cryptographically fair so unless you
break equipped oh you are essentially
even if you are a national state with
YouTube major you general computational
resources you can not enhance the
probability of being selected Peter and
if you win you actually get a winning
ticket a poll for the t1 and you are
part of this committee in if you don't
win you can talk but you're not taking
seriously about approving of this block
because you are nobody your opinion
doesn't count this time okay so when I
say lottery think about it with diesel
salata machine inside your computer each
one of us pull the lever and see if he
wins if he wins your winning ticket if
you don't you don't do not even and if
you have a winning ticket what you do
you propagate your winning ticket and
your opinion up and down or about the
block proposed by shutting right bits of
metal away otherwise you shout don't
loosen to sharpy but doesn't matter
you're not a winning ticket you can say
anything you want Bettis Vidya okay
in the alternative space good question
but but taking it into the first phase
is harder than the second phase and
that's why I'm focusing my attention on
bei a lot of things okay good catch
remember very much if it's one much to
talk to I decided to talk about magic
phase - all right okay
by the way this is what machine isn't
your only the one shot that there's a
lot the machine is not that saying oh
let me pull oh I don't mean let me pull
the lever again you get to the same
result even before so is the centuries a
single single user slot machine later
okay
that's what you have okay so now let me
argue that this is really super
decentralized yes and and bet is
actually perhaps the very highest
technical challenge because essentially
anytime you want to have you skipped Oh
guess what you must have inputs where do
you find inputs in a blockchain welcome
the blockchain itself oh but the
blockchain itself what do we record in
the blockchain the blocks will you ever
search create the transaction we were
self create so if I'm an anniversary I'm
going to tweak oh the blockchain so as
to kate a good input that allows them a
slot machine to win to prove with varies
some quantity that is
untampered enough even though and at the
very can choose the counter the block
that's the hard of a matter thank you
for bringing it up sorry but you brought
it up because this is a distraction okay
so because of any things to get
complicated but at the highlight a
little bit so what happens okay now let
me argue but this is super decentralized
of course this decentralized Agusan we
don't have that far some fixes people
who are in charge of its best time this
one person people who've been well
ordered this other type of this other
guy - in australia one malaysia
free in France right next time somebody
else so it is the centralized because
he's a really random lottery let me tell
you that base is super scalable because
what you have to do how much does it
take to pull the lever one microsecond
that's pretty fast
and by the way is not you first pull the
lever one microsecond when you pull the
lever
let's HUDs up but essentially it's think
of it but in the same microsecond
everybody pulls whatever i mean ii three
microseconds because this is not
synchronized the network right but i
think of it all this to people guru
later more or less in or around the same
time and and therefore base is super
scalable and what you do when you send
they know your opinion about the block
where the Super's but Betty's fast is a
short message so now let me argue at the
super secure well assume it I'm the big
scary guy but I was telling you about
and we have already argued that the
power is in the committee hive as magic
power of corrupting anybody I want whom
should I contact become me forever
problem I don't know who the committee
is should I go up you and you and your
best lady in the street this other guy
in Spain I don't know
I don't know until the committee
revealed itself by propagating the
winning ticket and their opener about
the block at that point I know who they
are and I can attack them wait a minute
a bet point attacking them it gives me
not nor been benefit why because the
winning ticket and their opener but the
block is virally being propagated of a
network and will continue to be we
attack them or not
I don't need my power to put back these
messages in the bottle no more than the
US government has the power to put back
in the bottle a message of virally
propagated by WikiLeaks so the system is
secure because ex ante I don't know whom
I go guard and exposed is too light to
corrupt them so if you put the base bet
gives you the beginning of analysis or
why that Jelena can actually work okay
it's not a fool analysis there are more
parts to trace to the system but you can
start getting if you do things weird
enough all these assumptions somehow
collapse by factor 2000 blockchains I
enjoy 2 out of 3 bobert it doesn't mean
that all of them should so by the way
wait a second these are Byzantine
Agreement a very slow well they are but
not the one we use we design from
scratch a new one which is actually
super fast because it takes a handful of
step and the every step
everybody has to propagate a single
short and easy to computer message that
is good but he's a bit more
sophisticated 10 minutes of a meeting
very good which means you know when I
did the analysis you know that's why
we're a jacket when I give this talk
because I hide that as many details for
as long as again you guys are forcing me
to get to know technical are also rude
you see why did he convince you but he
was secure because i propagate one one
winning ticket and one opener about the
block
but what I am saying here but I could
run the buzzient in agreement so I could
if I tell you I'm part of this Byzantine
agreement and when I tell you in the
same sentence and this only takes a few
steps or a few steps so when I send you
the proof of it I were entitled to speak
in best buds and in agreement
and my first mate said you cannot stop
him for the reason idea just to give you
not before and not after but if the same
person speaks a second time or a third
time now once you know what you are if
you have is magical power with the
mediator corruption you can corrupt when
them and control the second or third
message and who knows where better gets
you so the point here is because
convening a committee now and Esau takes
service easy so it is microsecond you
can afford to have independent committee
for each step of the Byzantine agreement
portable and and essentially that is a
new property and by the way that is one
of the best audiences of cryptographers
ever assembled you know that this is a
new property because you know we thought
we never thought about defining it's all
but solid ease because let me tell you
is a very easy to say different steps
different people but what type of an
intelligent conversation can you have
each step of a conversation is a
different about random selected people
who don't know each other right so to
have a plural or lease or bust that
continues to deliver meaningful
properties like a given the consistency
even though different people talk at the
same time and you don't even know who
they are that's hard
it is a unique I was really a member I
woke up with my wife say it's very bad
indeed a game in photo good player
replaceable okay I was so excited you
know I wasn't sleeping in there so so
here means these are that it's going to
step one is a green committee's that
Teresa is a red comedian so on so forth
right so let's see what is the
relationship between with the members of
this committee members
yeah okay because we randomly selected
occasionally you can happen vetting oh
maybe this guy is equal to this guy but
you know it could happen also know that
is there is no relationship they are
different players and by the way there
are also different numbers right because
is a lottery so sometimes you know you
have a thousand but you actually a bit
1100 or but signs of you have a now
hundred and fifty so you cannot even
much of a map I whatever Jordan say is a
corresponds to no there is not such a
thing and there is no shared variable
because Abed not know who else is going
to be selected and yet they act as if it
is a single committee from beginning to
end
okay and this ladies and gentlemen is to
be truly distributed in the presence of
a bad and powerful adversary because if
you tell me like many project head oh we
have a committee but we keepin in charge
for an hour we keep in charge for 10
minutes even in 10 minutes
I cannot go grab him the good
old-fashioned way knock knock you don't
know me that I'm a friend of yours here
is my bag of money to prove it by text
time right but at the Nile of service
attack that takes no time so if you
Putin for a day for an hour for a minute
is about the too late the only way to
say is that you only speak once and
therefore and corrupting doesn't matter
denial-of-service attack that's about it
that's the only way to go and by the way
then we have a new type of a power goal
I like vesicles as a logic structure
that allows us to reason the new polygon
actually as agreement on the fly as a
single kind of body and is resilient
against arbitrary Network partitions but
I know time to tell you I instead I'd
like to tell of a few minutes remaining
to me to tell you a little bit what
happens beyond the consensus first of
all let me start a bit with the Dutch
auction just to be a there are very
simple things we did not invent them we
are going to invent all kinds actually
home with inventor all kinds of all the
financial tools this is an all too
but is who knows who uses a Dutch
auctions every day governments including
our own to sell for instance bonds but
whom to buy sell it they sell it to
Goldman Sachs JP Morgan a few other
suspects who buy them on the cheap and
then release element to all of us at
higher prices is they're not really so
on the other side you have actually a
technological problem so you know this
is Dutch auction there is a descending
price and how do you know better in the
entire globe this everybody sees the
same descendant price that is a
technological challenge but I'm saying
that it's just a simple example what I
think the good outcome of versus not
only 12 payments payments is at the end
are easy
I didn't say because they are not but
there is it decentralized they're not so
simple to the decentralize not simple
but you know that toxin is the other
thing because what do you want to have
is an idea of a democratization of
Finance right which allows you to have
an essentially global participation by
everybody they hack the global
participation I think and you need the
technology for doing that and there is
technology to behave the next thing is
you know water you know random axis is
very important just think doing machines
nobody programs doing machines ok
unless you want to do a tooth but
otherwise you know people like to random
access so why one of the main sources of
centralization is a blockchain is the
name storage required to store batching
right so pretty soon will be a terabyte
so you want to join five minutes or
plenty it's join up Oh
download the best Arabic and then
participate you know next time and it's
pretty soon and if we produce blocks
faster than anybody else nobody can
store these things or very few people
can store the things we have
decentralize a centralization from an
another angle so what are they some both
the project is essentially is a way that
you obtain a very compact information
that you come up and you update a very
compact information
but so whenever you join the blockchain
you're given a compact information that
allows you to go forward exactly the
same way as someone who was from the
very beginning as stored event I chain
and in that you get also a proof with
this compact information is correct
because otherwise I can give you some
compact piece of information distort the
reports and best book is based on what
you know button based on the only thing
certain in a blockchain the Genesis
block okay so here is a proof again it's
based on region C blocks all you need to
know and he continued forward so and if
I want to store by chain
why should I store it well because if
you want to have asked a question about
a past transactions a five no blockchain
don't prevent people for suing each
other right we are in a democracy
everybody can sue anybody else so we did
say you didn't pay Oh actually yeah Amy
I was I did pay you a million alcázar
four years ago and I need to exhibit of
a poof so if I just join up a computer
information I have no idea what happens
three years ago but both of storm a
chain can actually provide it retriever
the block and actually convey the block
together with a proof the block is
correct based on the Genesis block in
Batesville where he works and by the way
we can generate a market so we get begin
with some incentive to people for doing
forensic analysis on certain things to
stop a change because otherwise you
don't need it to go forward but you may
need it for doing this why should I do
it hey because I want to or maybe
because it can be actually a piece of as
a deal then there is all kinds of atomic
swaps which means I give you something
if only began everything except the
hours are going to be atomic atomic swap
really atomic atomic swap because an
atomic swap our atomic just in name
there are time blocks all kinds of
things in both change without a block
finality atomicity doesn't really exist
smart contract a great side product of
the blockchain however they are not
really very smart are they so much so
but you cannot have a crypto kitten in a
nice yolk beacon
at the same time I kept OPP and is born
I don't know if you know about those is
a nice cute application to me they are
so damn intensive but you have to do
something else but I'd like to give me
the privacy on the blockchain you know
aliens are some great ideas on how to do
better and so on so forth but I'd like
to stop here at best self-governance
because if you understood and I wrap it
up here consensus mechanism is actually
buttoned in agreement all visa proofer
work was invented to make possible to
agree invested eluded fashion easily but
once we get the budget agreement to work
easily we can agree on anything
what do we agree upon 99.9 percent of
the time on the next block but we could
agree on a new monetary policy a new
rule got a new improvement of a protocol
by the same kind of easy and I believe
it actually this self governance which
requires not only aspirational we want
to be self governed everybody wants
right except the dictator so they don't
want you to self-govern but otherwise
but the question is we need technology
because if I say I'm against base and I
blog at three times a day doesn't mean
they have a three times the more
community behind me now yeah just I mean
I blog more I blog in capital later blog
you know bugging on the table it doesn't
mean anything so you need to have a
mechanism for doing this and I think
better hi now Drock chains have been
ocean liners on autopilot they set the
rules and never change
you said course iceberg nor iceberg in
otaku not that boom I mean life is about
intelligent adaptation and so the best
thing we do in life is actually either
preserve ability to evolve in a
consensual manner and so what I think
about the agreement that consensus a
missile I'll grant is going to be good
and that is actually the really the way
to do a borderless economy right so I
really believe a bit you know is a
matter of space I think a Barrera
everybody took up very
a high bar I believe is not a winner
Tigers all there is going to be whom for
a few blockchain but ultimately if you
really want to set free and to have a
borderless economy you really need
technology ok so that is going to be
even more the thing and speaking of
technology here is an old piece of
technology but actually is being a built
in South and France is a impressive
piece of technology but allowed the
people living a across the river to meet
and transact with each other and it's a
beautiful structure you must admit and
also it's so strong that nobody repaired
for many many many years thousands of
years of fact and still stains and until
2005 they allow cars to cross the bridge
did we figure out perhaps is a bad idea
ok so I believe I bet I know the
blockchain infrastructure is going to be
as useful to bridge as as humanity to
one another and it's going to be as
beautiful and any other physical
infrastructure that we have built for
similar purposes and in fact if we build
it correctly we are going to be able to
keep the planet up the planet hopper is
a artists job but you know after a few
years of doing so it looks a bit tired
so well it's thinking for is the job and
we'll take it from here thank you very
much
[Applause]
both flicks wanna trace this seems to
require randomness selection processes
be truly random so I'm thinking what if
the source of the randomness is broken
suppose it's a pseudo-random number
generator is there an actual risk around
that or is it simply too fast for
something like that you should budget
the mystical be done by the way they say
in all architectural of things it's very
easy if you if you really want I can
actually answer of course there is a
risk it should be well designed but it's
very simple idea it is much more
important to get the idea because once
you say that you can be done you can
leave it on exercise too
but gadget stewards right here it is
that is a really very easy part and then
perhaps I take on service equation
that's it so how do we do this right
I'll do implement the samuri the easiest
way to do it by the way the fancy way to
do it is to use you know verifiable
random function forget it I cannot even
define it and in five minutes but this
is essentially all the property to give
your idea so you have your unique
signature think about RSA right so you
know probably the signature your board
unique signature and you have idea
lation that you can actually model as
but it means that the signature of M
everybody can verify an adolescent think
of it alike is a random string compress
the string then what you do so you want
to say I belongs to committee are if
there only if dot ash Sigma Q R is less
than P sorry I didn't understand of
course because I didn't have time to
explain it but what is P P is a
probability say one in a thousand that's
it easy and what is rescue our bet is a
magically determined quantity which is
something but the even though is depends
on the blockchain is
very very hard to manipulate by the
anniversary so think of it there is like
fixed and not available to their
diversity what is this that is the
deterministic signature by of this
unique QR right and what is this that
means the base is independent of a it is
a unique string and if s is a unique
signature of a unique string it's a
unique string associated Y and what is
the best stuff over here is a random
function so what that means that this
means is because vest is a unique string
associated to our best is a unique
random string associated Y and what is
the summer stuff but is the decimal
point of a binary point if you want okay
so if that means that all the stuff is a
random number between 1 and 0 associated
Y and so what is the probability but
best number random number uniquely
associated Y is less than P is P okay so
in other words if you do this I belongs
to CRE probability 1 over a thousand so
if there is a million people and you
want to have roughly a thousand
committee you set the P equal to a
thousand and you do just that if you
have an hour billion users and you want
to select a thousand you select the P to
be one in a million
because a billion divided a million is
the natural phone isn't busy this is
easy so the only thing is in some sense
is to make sure because this Q R changes
to our changes changes and not God
doesn't Bend
million so when I fixed different people
what changes in this formula P only QR
is selected in the same way no matter
what the probabilities because QR what
is coming we want to generate the block
I in the quantities QR when you select
one to select block B block R plus one
you need to have a proposer R plus one
and you need the commedia plus one and
the purpose of the committee are
selected in the same way no I want the
same thousand is always the same the
Committees of a thousand but because the
number of the tokens that can be
increased because if we put in situation
with time so it may right by the way how
do we put the money in circulation we
don't they are they are gone foundation
do how do they do it by Dutch auctions
okay so how does it like election good
so if you work if you want to take a
bunch of identical items like tokens are
but no it may work like this
they were to say well what is a bit a
bit ease well for a maximum ten dollars
I'm willing to spend $1,000 so I make
sure that I get to know a few items
however for a maximum of five bucks I'm
ready to buy 10,000 items and for a
maximum of one dollar I'm ready to buy
ultra fast on of them okay so you post
some bits like this on became so
everybody's transparent you see the
beads dots by others and whatnot and
that auction do they compute by first
price at which you can sell all the
tokens for sale birthday right assume
that that price is two dollars and
making it up
right so when you say who mesh you read
for a maximum ten bucks you buy a fuss
and token here there's a fuss and tokens
is your lucky day because the price is
two so you buy a father and talk about
price or - wait a second you also said
that you wanted 10,000 targets or a
maximum price of five here is an
additional 10% talk back so - you also
said you 100% talked about maximum
sorry at the price of two we sold them
all right it's a bit it's a bit sort of
it so tokens are put in circulation
periodically by Dutch auctions why Dutch
auctions because assume with it I tell
you is a fixed price and I set up a
price and the price is too you say is
nice a fair price it's a very pay
equation if you say well we don't make
the price you do you cannot complain
it's a market that driven the situation
right and no it's always fair because
you choose the prize in this fair
because you see but all the bids of
everybody because nobody can can stop
them and everybody realizes what the
begad Pisces is a way better and they
say mechanism by the way the foundation
will do it for auctioning off for the
tokens but you can actually use it and
for auctioning off say a building if you
want to post a blockchain on a building
right because if you want to post a
blockchain an office here in Berkeley
there is so much you know startup so
much talent you want to a bar an office
building to get all all these startups
and you build it if you sell it locally
you have local billionaires real estate
investors who can pretty much will set
the price for you if you put to them the
blockchain you get billionaires for far
away but still very few but if you
allowed to sell them fractional
ownership be a distraction you allow me
from Boston to participate in for
$10,000 bid to get a piece of your
building then you really realize your
the value of the building and I am very
happy to have the ability being far away
to participate directly in something
like this right so
actually no you need of the fact of it
inductively the blockchain is common
knowledge and beta and yet to be very
very careful on our Yorkist rated as
quantity Q are the analysis of content
war is no except for BAE no no no no no
no only the reason it's a random or
brush function and that's it because
every time that you do a coin flip in
the protocol you to be very careful
about it's very easy to flip cones when
you have a fixed number of Committee
because that is you take a multi-party
computation right i I share 0 you share
one you share one then we decrypt all of
us together right and then you get the
same model or to orbit's bits and
there's a common big but now we have a
fixed committee so once your non
subcommittee it can be attacked it can
be something so we we don't we have a
different way to approach of a problem
so beta a we shift our soundness and
lionize differently so to make sure that
the you never have been arguing the
fixed committing charge of anything
acceptable for a secret committee speak
only once
[Applause]